AI is the most profound technology that
I think we're working on today and it is
not just a profound technology for
technology but also has a huge
opportunity for the UK you cited the 400
billion pound figure that's the economic
impact we think this can have by 2030 so
actually growing the economy each year
by 2.6 percent uh which is a huge
Improvement in terms of the growth
trajectory that the country is currently
on
for that to happen though the UK will
need to invest more in research and
development invest more in skills I mean
these are unfortunately things where the
UK lags a lot of its peer economies
I think that r d investment will be key
I think skills investment is also going
to be critical we actually just trained
our 1 millionth Learner in the UK around
digital skills and I think making sure
everyone can participate in the Advent
of not just AI but the overall digital
skills transformation is going to be
critical to unrealize realizing this
opportunity now you also notes that the
UK will require more in in computing
power as it were why do we lag other
economies in this respect right now
I think computing power actually quite
strong and I think we need to continue
our investment in this area I think it
is a AI certainly from a technical
standpoint requires a lot of compute
power so we'll need to remain rigorous
in terms of our investment there
but why is the UK behind some of its
peers
currently actually the UK is in a pretty
good spot in terms of our compute
capacity and I think the question is can
we keep pace and continue investing at
that level it's going to be critical for
us to continue to have a leadership
position in AI
there's a big debate as to whether AI is
going to create or destroy jobs are we
framing the question in the right way
I think jobs is a really important topic
for us to be talking about I do think
there will be some jobs that are
fundamentally transformed and the
majority of jobs will fundamentally
change in terms of how they use AI in
their in the work that they do every day
personally I'm using kind of auto
correct and all the techniques in Gmail
to be faster and more productive in the
work I do every single day there will be
jobs that are lost but I think the
bigger opportunity will be the next
Generation jobs that are created and
that's why we're so focused on the
skills agenda making sure everyone has
the skills they need to succeed in this
new wave of technologically abled growth
obviously though AI is going to render
some tasks and some jobs obsolete I mean
what sort of things should my kids be
studying at school right now what sort
of careers should they be looking at if
they're not going to get swept away by
this technology well I think it's
actually getting that balance right
between having that kind of well-rounded
education that helps you understand that
the possibility of Technology but the
application to whatever you're
passionate about I think AI is
fundamentally going to transform
everything that we're working on today
and make our lives better
um and I think those that know how to
use those tools the AI driven tools for
Innovation and creativity are really
going to be the ones that are going to
succeed in the future
what sort of things are you looking for
in Google UK and Ireland now as regards
new recruits
oh well we're always looking for for
great talent at Google
um and I we are fortunate to be a great
employer here we have actually 6 500
folks uh based in the UK across a
variety of areas so we have 50 of our
staff are actually in technical roles so
product and engineering and 50 of our
staff are in sales and marketing General
administrative kind of roles so there's
a huge uh range of career options at
Google here in the UK I mean that's what
really interests me about your career
because you started out as of anchor at
Goldman Sachs you've set up your own
business you've worked at the likes of
Viacom and Unilever I mean yours is not
what you might call a traditional Tech
background
uh well thank you for setting up on my
background that is true I've Had A
diversity of experiences I actually
think diverse experiences make for an
interesting career
um and I think I've learned different
things from each of those experiences
that make me a better professional today
so certainly I would encourage your kids
as they're thinking of setting out on
their Journeys to be less focused on the
specific job but more about the set of
skills that they want to assemble from
different experiences they might have
what do you think people are skeptical
though about the transformative
potential of AI I mean for example
Jeffrey Hinton sometimes called the
Godfather of AI I mean he's just left a
senior role at Google
yes I think that AI because it is such a
profound technology I think the
opportunity for it to be incredibly
powerful in solving some of society's
biggest problems climate change Health
um you know we just launched a tool that
helps you anticipate floods and the
impact that can happen in communities
around the world that's incredible at
the same time we know that powerful
technology we need to be really
responsible about how it's deployed so
at Google we take this balanced approach
to being both bold and responsible at
the same time we launched AI principles
many years ago that actually govern the
way we are deploying Ai and we're really
rolling it out in a very measured
cautious way to make sure those benefits
come forward that 400 billion pound
economic value for the UK that we see
um so available for us by 2030 but at
the same time do it in a responsible way